eric in phoenix arizona what's going on
hey john so my wife and i just had a
baby a couple months ago
congratulations my brother thanks my
brother wants to come visit us for
thanksgiving but
he's had a history of some drug issues
and so we're having trouble
deciding whether we enforce a boundary
um
or maybe don't enforce the boundary and
try to save the relationship
okay tell me about the drug issues
first so it's mostly marijuana that we
know of but like
a lot of this is secondhand right so we
don't know everything he's doing we just
know
that it's been going on for five or six
years and um
and it's just hard to it's hard to talk
about it he never wants to talk about it
when we
uh when i try to bring it up it always
kind of gets heated
um what is it when you say it gets
heated it kind of gets heated what does
that mean
well we have different opinions about
like you know you could say politically
about whether marijuana is good or not
sure um but we like i've seen how it
just
it doesn't help him much it does and
maybe he just uses too much of it you
know
and so you know if we ever so we just
avoid that subject but he knows that
we've got this boundary that hey you
need to
pass a clean drug test if you want to
come see your nephew
and we're at the point where we're not
sure if he's going to pass it and so
are you guys giving him the drug test
um is he on probation
yeah so he my parents have been giving
him drug tests and so they were going to
give it to him before he
came out like with them because he's
still living at home right now
why are they giving him drug tests
they've set boundaries for him too
saying if you don't pass a drug test you
know you're kicked out of the house you
know
and they've done that a couple times but
they always let them back in okay and so
that's the other hard thing is we we
want to set a sperm boundary because we
feel like he's never
had that you know so
it sounds like there's two issues here
one is you are feeling
like you need to lean in and become the
parent that your parents are not being
for your brother
that's number one number two is you are
trying to determine whether there's a
safety issue
with your new child is that fair
right and honestly well yeah and
honestly it's not a safety issue
so much with uh him like i don't believe
he's going to be
dangerous or violent or anything we just
um but we want to we want to stick true
to our word because we want that to mean
something too you know
yeah i want to say we're going to do
something and then don't do it i get
that and so
when you say you gave this word right
you put something
you you drew a line here's my values
which you're allowed to have your values
right
did you tell him that did you all have a
conversation about it how did he get
that information
we told him probably over a year ago
before we were even pregnant because we
had some
miscarriages in the past and so we had
told him hey this is going to be
a thing for the future i think you're
going to think about and we reminded him
again during the pregnancy and and that
was just over text message but he was
like yep okay
and and it's been weird because he's
been talking more he doesn't talk to me
directly about it
he always i hear stuff secondhand to my
parents
yeah so how old are you i'm 25
okay how old is he 22. okay
so it's time for you to be a grown-up
and i'm not saying that i'm not making
fun of you i'm just saying
there's you're about to level up now
okay uh you're a dad
you're a husband you're in it now okay
and there's these moments
when young men level up young women do
it too but i'm just talking to you right
now
so you're going to level up and that
means you are absolutely 100
through having any sort of meaningful
conversation
whatsoever to anybody in your life on
text message
cool a text message can be about
um what time are y'all showing up
tonight hey my flight got delayed i'll
be there at six that stuff's cool
but when you're gonna lay down value
statements like you cannot see this baby
if you are not passing a drug test
that's a in person conversation and if
he doesn't want to have it
you can tell him i've got some stuff
that i need to talk to you about my new
baby
and my small family when you're ready to
be grown up and have a conversation give
me a call
okay and he's gonna have to level up to
but number one this is not a
a conversation for um text message
number two
i want you and your wife to sit down and
make some clear
like what is the purpose of this value
this value judgment
like i said do you think that somebody's
smoking weed
or who smoked weed a few days ago who's
gonna come and then
see their new nephew or their niece is
going to harm the child or hurt the
child
if that's what you think and believe and
you've got some wisdom
i've never seen that but i also know
that everybody's different okay
if that's what your kid if you're
worried about the safety of your baby
that's a no
quarter thing nobody gets a vote on the
safety of your kid you draw hard
boundaries to where you think they
should be and you hold firm to them
if a year ago you had
like you were leaning into trying to
support your parents and saying yeah and
not only you're not going to get to live
with mom and dad but you're not going to
be able to see your new niece
and you sent that via text message i'm
going to tell you've got full permission
to circle back to your brother have a
grown-up brother to brother conversation
about man how are you doing and
we're getting ready to be in the
holidays mom and dad have asked you to
quit smoking
and they have said this is part of their
rules that you're gonna for you to live
in their house you keep failing them
what's what's going on bro because you
cannot bring drugs into my house
you can't because whatever state we live
in they're illegal i don't want them
here it's my house i get to make that
rule
what i don't want you to do man eric is
i don't want you to use your kid
as uh for ransom for your brother
i don't want you to use a powerful
relationship between
nephew or niece and an uncle
as as a way as a behavior manipulation
tool
because that's never going to work it's
not going to help him get sober
and that's not going to help you
feel better and so it sounds like
there's something deeper here if i'm if
i'm
leaning into it it sounds like you are
frustrated with your parents
you're frustrated with your brother and
you are trying to take this on is that
fair or am i out to lunch on that
yeah i mean there's a piece of it that's
very true there i think the other
the other part of the boundary that we
set was also for
my wife's brothers there's a couple
one in particular that has probably some
more serious drug issues that would be
more
of a safety concern yeah and so i think
i think that we're trying to
set a boundary we're saying hey we're
enforcing this fairly on both sides
relationships aren't fair relationships
aren't fair
um and don't feel that pressure
right if one is has a conviction
for selling cocaine and the other is
just out of being a teenager and got in
trouble for smoking marijuana those are
two different planets
as far as i'm concerned yeah and it does
make it easier on you guys just to do a
blanket
you know big square fence around the
house and again those are if these are
your values
dude go for it there is not going to be
an easy way to enforce these
boundaries and what i mean by easy
there's not going to be a way that
people don't walk away from your fence
that you build
with their hearts broken that's life
and if if addiction was as easily
it was cured as easy as just saying well
then you can't do this until you're done
we would have no addiction
problems but addiction is often a
connection issue
it's a relationship issue and so instead
of putting up roadblocks now it doesn't
have to be your kid hear me say that
but if you really want to help your
brother
deep in your relationship with him
connect with him
reach out to him talk to him once a week
twice a week via phone go visit him you
all set up camping trips together
and you lean into that relationship then
you will earn the currency to say hey
what's really going on
and he might say you had the same mom
and dad as me you know exactly what's
going on
or you know about this or you know some
stuff that i never told you
and it may be that he chooses smoking
weed
and you choose to work 90 hours a week
you're both running
yours is just socially acceptable and
his isn't right
or it may be that he's just he's a
a punk 22 year old who just wants to get
high doesn't care what other people say
and he needs to be slopped upside the
head and not living at mom and dad's
house and not mooching free meals off
holidays
right only you know that but i don't
think you have to draw a comparison
between a safety issue and a 22 year old
who
may smoke weed a week before he comes to
see you those seem like
radically different things to me and you
just have to make peace with the fact
that you have a kid now
and every boundary you draw from here
now it's going to be hard
somebody's gonna hit up against that
boundary with their face and their
forehead and their feet and their fists
and their
knees and their and their and their
entire body is trying to knock those
boundaries over
and you're gonna have to hold firm to
them you and your wife are
and so what i would circle back here's
how i would approach this moving forward
i would circle back eric and i would
have a conversation with your wife
conversation number one is what are we
trying to do what are we trying to
accomplish
is all of this stuff because we don't
want that one brother she has
who's a violent offender or who makes
dangerous decisions with drugs coming to
our house for the holidays because if
so call it what it is don't punish other
family members for one person's
idiocracy
or one person's illness or one person's
struggle
don't do that so get with your wife and
say what are we really trying to
accomplish are we trying to have a
drug-free house if so
sweet send that notice to everybody call
them in person
hey you cannot come here unless you pass
a drug test to walk in my house
okay i don't i don't know anybody doing
that but you are free to do that okay
um if you want to help co-parent your
brother he's 22 he's a grown man
stop doing that be his brother love him
lean into him
lean into him my brother and i who i
love more than life itself
we've had some great conversations over
the year i gave him some behavioral
mandates at one point
that wasn't super helpful but i was
young and thought i was you know like
i'll i'll be there right
i said you can do these things you can't
do these things or i'm going to show up
and then you have to deal with me or
whatever and i don't know if that was
helpful probably not
threatening someone you love is usually
not the best way but um
i also loved him and i was trying to
love him the best way i could
so if you back out eric um
what are you really trying to accomplish
here
yeah i i mean i want to circle up with
my wife like you said but i
i do think that it's more of more of
that safety for the other brother and i
definitely want to
i don't want to be don't want to don't
want to hold this boundary i would
rather have him come i'd rather have him
meet his
um his nephew because that's the other
thing is he is he is by far like the
most excited but he cried when he found
out we were pregnant no one else
like my parents didn't even cry like
he's excited and so i wanna i really
wanna
nurture that relationship and does your
wife like it build a relationship
oh yeah well he can be annoying but
that's a brother
man you should see you talk to my
brother and sister i'm the most annoying
guy there is man so yeah
um when it comes dude yeah when it comes
to him um
you haven't told me anything that would
say no you can't be here
you can full full fledge that you will
not come into my house hi
i have told that to people that i love
right
you can't yeah and that's a different
thing hi you can't come to my house with
drugs you got to be safe when you come
to my house
but you're welcome here um i dude i love
that you want to
deepen that relationship with him i i
mean that's noble that's noble
let your parents be parents and you be
the brother and now that you're both in
your 20s you're both
grown-ups now you're both on your way to
becoming wise grown men
seek some other men in your life that
can speak into this relationship
you be the guy that goes first lean into
your brother
love him the best that you know how and
then when you don't say
what are you missing man how can i be a
better brother have that conversation
for how's that for vulnerability right
and yeah talk to your wife about what
your values are and how you're going to
rally around your kid
and never be too big this is a this is
something i want to say to everybody
never be too big to say i drew a really
hard boundary a year ago
and a year later that was dumb
i mean i overshot that one right
like i you know we all know that person
that when they
have their first kid you go into their
house and they're spraying you down with
lysol and making you wash your hands
this is pre-covered of course
and take your shoes off and leave them
out in the yard we all know those people
and then a year later they're like dude
yeah whatever and they're picking the
the pacifier out of the dog food bowl
and just shoving it back in the kid's
mouth
don't be too big to say i drew a line it
was wrong
that's the world we're in right now with
politics and media
right i said it four years ago and if i
go back and change my mind because i've
got new data
i got new science i got new uh
relationship
relational information i can't change my
mind because everybody's nuts
the sign of a evolving
wise mind is that they hold their values
tightly
and their beliefs loosely and they are
not afraid to say i'm sorry
they're not afraid to say man i screwed
that up i want to go again
so good for you eric lean into that
brother but start with your wife start
with a values conversation